So, as for
our negotiations with Alexandra,
Lukashenko and Belarus were just
the reason, probably the statement by the
British Deputy Minister of Defense that
they are going to supply shells to
Ukraine with combined damage, I
repeat. This is somehow connected with
nuclear technology, this is an obvious thing
on But
even without the context of these  events of
this statement,
Alexander Grigorievich Lukashenko has long been
raising the question of placing
Russian
tactical nuclear weapons on the territory of Belarus, in this sense he is
right, he says, Well, listen, we are your
closest allies. Why do the Americans
do this with their ally on their
territory? By the way, they train
their crews  their pilots to use
these weapons if necessary, we
agreed that we did the same
without violating our obligations, I want to
emphasize this without violating our
international obligations not to
spread
nuclear weapons, we have already helped our
Belarusian colleagues convert their
Airplanes Aircraft of the Belarusian Air Force 10
aircraft are ready for use of this
type  the first weapons, we have already
transferred to Belarus
our well-known very effective complex
from Counter
and it can also be a carrier, from
April 3rd we will begin training
and on
July 1st we will complete
the construction of a
special storage facility for tactical
nuclear weapons on the territory